anyway joining us now with reaction
former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka NRA TV contributor
former Secret Service agent Dan bond
Geno let's start with you dr. korkor
it's a pretty fundamental thing all the
things that the the mayor said last
night the president attorney said last
night about Hillary about Muller about
Comey about the investigation huge news
that he's making here and they focus on
30 seconds because that's where the
corrupt media goes they don't want to
hear the truth
first things first Shawn I have to
congratulate you because you're getting
close to the president's record for
living rent-free in the mind of the
liberal left media obsessed with you
they're obsessed with you and I like how
they spend the whole day I followed it
all day how they they they selected 1/2
a sentence from the mayor's statement on
your show but they missed the beginning
where he said amongst other things
that's the reason why he was fired these
people haven't even past year one in
journalism school and they have to
maintain a narrative it's like those 49
questions those 49 questions are a mark
of desperation there is no case there is
no conclusion so three-quarters of those
questions are about trying to police
your thought we only do that in
dictatorships we don't do that in
America Shawn yeah and by the way these
are the actual questions what did you
think about commis testimony what did
you think about sessions recusal what
did you think about the appointment of
his special counsel it doesn't matter
what he thought no it matters what he
did and and the fact that that that goes
over their head in the water infuriates
me on the other hand I got a laugh damn
Bungie you know look at this that Rudy
Giuliani the president's attorney talked
about how Muller's questions are a
perjury trap he talked about Comey we
just played it being a disgraceful liar
and and how the probe is tainted he
talked about how Hillary's a criminal
belongs
in jail and that Comey fixed the entire
case with Hillary then he talked about
how Comey should be prosecuted for
leaking confidential information none of
that for the most part is covered today
but the only thing they cover is stormy
stormy and they even got that wrong well
Sean they're invested in this now they
can't get away from the Russia hoax
they're embedded in this they've they've
sold it to us for a year but Sean this
is a case built by Liars for Liars the
three Liars clapper Brennan and call me
they built this on a bed of Lies as
collusion hoax for Liars up on Capitol
Hill and people in the media that had to
obstruct the Trump presidency with a
fake collusion hoax this is nonsense and
on the topic of the question Sean let me
just tell you when I was a Secret
Service agent I went to a very
sophisticated advanced interrogation
school they actually came into our
training center one of the things they
always taught us when you're trying to
get people into a trap in an interview
is ask open-ended questions in other
words don't ask is your name Sean
Hannity you're just gonna say yes an
open-ended question would be well what's
your name because if you're involved in
an identity theft case you may slip up
and actually give the wrong name that's
what they're trying to do do not do this
interview it is a huge mistake it's a
trap what do you think sebastian to that
very point the president right now i've
been saying this from the beginning
should never ever sit down Joe Victoria
are right they have no right to do this
the president cannot be indicted at the
end of the day this is a perjury trap
nothing more nothing less
this man wants a scout Mulla wants a
scalp and along with comeon mccabe they
have destroyed the reputation of the FBI
I'm getting text today from FBI agents
saying they they record every meeting
they go to now because jurors no longer
believe them Sam and have this thing
it's not no no I'm not I will never
sleep with a broad-brush here this is a
this is a few at the top not the rank
and file and Dan you've said you've
worked with these guys we know how great
they are they're great they are they're
terrific but Shawn all they listen to me
guys they have nothing
do you understand Muller has nothing you
can't fabricate collusion that didn't
happen this isn't Back to the Future
with Marty McFly there's nothing here
Shawn
so what do they have though all they
have is process crimes lying to the FBI
and a perjury trap they have nothing for
them when you think for the President of
the United States you would think they
put the country first here but for them
to succeed their culture it's about them
it's not about America that is sad